direkt zum start dieser neuen heute
staffel ein echter paukenschlag die
wahlen in sachsen und brandenburg
bescheren union und spd dramatische
verluste und beide volksparteien hd
schaffen es trotzdem wieder sich das
ganze irgendwie schön zu reden ja wir
sind im landtag aber klar ich meine tief
drin sind sie schon schockiert und
enttäuscht
sogar michael kretschmer der sächsische
ministerpräsident bleiben darf und
obwohl wir in dieser sendung das wissen
sie wirklich sehr sehr ungern
versprecher zeigen mache ich jetzt hier
gleich mal eine kleine ausnahme weil
dieser versprecher hier wenn sie genau
hinhören ungewollt eine tiefer liegende
wahrheit frei legt der krismer haben sie
eigentlich trotz oder wegen der bundes
cdu vergleichsweise gut abgeschnitten
wären gut abgeschlossen weil wir
zusammengehalten haben
nein wirklich
normalerweise machen wir das nicht aber
es hat ja kommt leute das niveau
beibehalten
man muss schon sagen speziell der
kretschmann hat tatsächlich ganz gut
abgeschlossen und ja und er hat vor
allem einen fulminanten wahlkampf
hingelegt im endspurt außerdem steht er
in blender im vergleich zur sächsischen
spd 7,7 prozent für die sozialdemokratie
eine katastrophe was soll man dazu noch
sagen wir haben das schlechteste
wahlergebnis wir sind auch mit der
coolste landes und wer jubelt da
ehrlich wieviel hektoliter
rotkäppchen-sekt muss man sich rein
schrauben nutzen und union haben noch im
januar ganz tolle ideen für die neuen
länder aufgeschrieben lohnangleichung
mehr behörden für den osten fast nichts
davon ist gekommen oder grundrente würde
auch seit zehn jahren versprochen ich
sag mal so macht man es der afg halt
auch ein bisschen zu leicht was haben
die da abgeräumt letzten sonntag was
haben sie ab geworden ja ja ja
andererseits muss man ja vor der afg gar
keine angst mehr haben
wussten sie das sind ja neuerdings die
sind ja eine die sind eine wie heißt
noch dieses das letzte adjektiv das
einem cfd einfällt wir sind eine
bürgerliche partei bürgerliche politik
der bürgerliche mehrheit bürgerliche
partei dass wir bürgerlich sind
bürgerliche bürgerlich bürgerlich
bürgerlich bürgerliche können sie sich
bürgerlich beziehungsweise reichs
bürgerlich meine damen und herren
aber an dieser stelle vielleicht auch
mal einen moment für selbstkritik wir
von der heute show haben immer gedacht
wenn man nur akribisch nachweist wie
rechtsextrem teile der afg inzwischen
sind dann hören die leute auf die zu
wählen ist falsch man kann mit
rechtsextremen inhalten ein viertel der
wähler holen ein viertel das ist fakt
meine damen und herren ja zumindest
zumindest in sachsen und brandenburg
jeder vierte klar hat auch mit
strukturschwachen regionen zu tun da
sagen dann manche bei mir fährt kein bus
mehr
deswegen hat sich ausländer andreas
kalbitz afg chef von brandenburg war
mindestens 15 jahre am stück in der
rechtsextremen szene hier zum beispiel
2007 beim pfingsttreffen der
heimattreuen deutschen jugend ist so
eine art fähnlein fieselschweif für
nazis wieso geht man dahin als
bürgerlicher politiker der kontext war
dass man weiß dass man erfahren hat es
gibt da an organisationen die sich für
jugendarbeit interessiert oder was macht
in die in der richtung
das hat mich mal generell interessiert
wie hart das war eine phase da habe ich
mich für jugendarbeit interessiert und
mit mit schwerpunkt hitlerjugend arbeit
war einfach die zeit auch herr calvins
gibt sich als kämpfer für mehr
meinungsfreiheit aber sollte er was gott
verhüten möge mal an die macht kommen
dann werden garantiert nicht nur
kriminelle ausländer abgeschoben
wer deutschland nicht liebt soll
deutschland verlassen
ich stelle mir das vor begründen so eine
never come back airline wir kriegen den
flieger voll mit den claudia roth den
champs de mars und wie sie alle heißen
pro sozial zurück
es werden super klingelte und wenn die
johanna zurück ja mach mal
tatsache ist auch für leute wie andreas
kalbitz den mann vom berühmten rechten
flügel der afd gibt es in deutschland
gibt es in deutschland einen markt punkt
ja ja demokratie muss auch wehtun waren
sind ein spiegel der gesellschaft
immerhin ist deutschland auch dank afd
wieder politisiert und man weiß ab
sofort ich habe immer die wahl zwischen
unserer seiner liberalen
parlamentarischen demokratie so mühsam
wie sie manchmal ist oder der herrschaft
des sogenannten volkswillens wobei mit
volk natürlich nur menschen deutschen
blutes gemeint sind die irgendwie
wertvoller sind als andere
natürlich radikalisiert sich dieser afd
aber schadet ja auch nicht und welche
partei kann sie ihre fans schon
aussuchen das wählen sie so fd und zwölf
stimme npd das heißt die ns zeit finde
ich auch gut so wieso sie sie finden
hitler und so finden dürfte wunderbar
wunderbar hat man auch nicht oft dass
sich leute den mittelteil ihres
schnurrbart einschreiben
na gut in sachsen haben laut umfragen 70
prozent die alternative für deutschland
nicht als denkzettel gewählt sondern
wegen ihrer politischen inhalte und
keineswegs nur wütende alte männer bei
den 18 bis 24 jährigen ist die afb die
stärkste kraft dort drüben trägt jetzt
die ostdeutsche jugendkultur jeder gibt
sogar für kinder eine neue reihe die
sogenannte ronny büchel ronny glaubt
nicht an den klimawandel
ronny kriegt seine erste hunde krawatte
und ronny mag ein döner ja so früh geht
es los allerdings könnte der ganze fd
triumph für sachsen und brandenburg noch
zum problem werden bei denen geht es ja
jetzt schon massiven fachkräftemangel in
den neuen ländern leben heute genau so
wenig menschen die 1905 und wer will da
noch in nach dieser wahl
sachsen hat die lösung der freistaat
sachsen und seine neue aktion wutbürger
zu fachkräften kurz ufa nutzt jetzt eine
aufgestaute wut aus endlosen brigida
gelang ihm dringend benötigten berufen
wie landarzt als adac-pannenhelfer
elektriker oder bäckereifachverkäufer
schokokuss pulse und bürger zu
fachkräften hast du mich dein leben lebe
deinen ass
problem gelöst
ja
der letzte war sonntag dieser
historische wahlsonntag eine schöne
gelegenheit mal einen lebenden sachsen
zu fragen was zum teufel hat ihr euch da
zusammen gewählt hashtag westi arroganz
olaf schubert
ja
oder es ist ja jetzt wirklich nicht die
zeit für westdeutsche arroganz was mich
besonders traurig gemacht hat laut
umfragen haben gerade ostdeutsche das
gefühl nicht mehr ihre meinung sagen zu
dürfen woran liegt das
ich glaube dass das so nicht stimmt also
meinen man darf alles sagen ich hab das
auch getestet das problem ist wenn man
wirklich alles sagt das dauert stunden
und viel wichtiger ist er glaube ich die
reaktion auf das gesprochene und da
werden wir ja alle immer empfindlicher
nein so einen politischen austausch
situation wird klar wenn dann rutscht
ein mal was raus dann sagt man irgendwie
doom ist stirbt und ich kotze auf dein
grab
und ja da merkt man das so da fühlen
sich dann einige gleich angegriffen dann
heißt ja da will mich umbringen ich
meine so einen quatsch also stirbt das
ist ja nur eine handlungsempfehlung und
das schaukelt sich dann irgendwie hoch
und dann wird eben schnell unhöflich
kann passiert große frage ist jetzt wie
geht man um mit dem erfolg der afg alle
sagen zu recht du kannst ja nicht ein
viertel der wähler der menschen
ignorieren wie gehst du im alltag mit
der fdp werde nun ein viertel kann man
schon ignorieren also ich sag mal so in
meiner familie vier köpfe ich werde wird
meine stimme seit jahren ignoriert
komplett zum wohle der familie denn wenn
ich was zu sagen hätte wäre die familien
ja schon lange ausgelöst also natürlich
ist es andererseits schwer jetzt
komplett auszugrenzen also ich habe es
so gemacht zu hause so angeht so
feiertag geburtstag weihnachten dann
habe ich in der verwandtschaft die mit
den rechten tendenzen ausgeladen dann
feiert der halt alleine so das ist jetzt
dann sitzt du da irgendwie möglich genau
mit onkel hedwig das kann jetzt auch
nicht sein dass ich jetzt aber alles
schon wieder so business eine negative
tendenz und ich finde ich muss und wir
jetzt auch mal ein plädoyer halten für
meinen sächsischen heimat freistaat ich
finde so viel zeit muss sein denn man
darf jetzt auch nicht alles
das leben geht ja normal weiter wenn man
den ariernachweis die schulen sind
geöffnet es gibt lebensmittel und sogar
bananen und ich die lichtgestalt aus
dunkel deutschland rufe euch zu menschen
römer und sonstige komm mit nach sachsen
ich weiß es ist weit weg von hier ist
aktiv im osten das ist er polen also man
kann sagen super - das ist gefühlt schon
großraum großraum tokio also ich sage
man die essen noch kartoffeln aber schon
mit stechen
ich rufe euch zu fürchtet euch nicht der
sachse ist ja nicht böse ist fällt uns
nur schwer unsere liebe zu zeigen aber
bei uns ist es so schön gerade für
männliche singles besonders für die
alleinstehenden lohnt sich eine reise
nach sachsen wird wo die schönen mädchen
verwachsen
die weiber im osten sind wirklich eine
reise wert und da meine ich wirklich nur
eine erleben sie auch unser winterliche
zwei nachts brauchtum wenn sie da sein
wollen zu weihnachten fahren sie
spätestens morgen los die meisten
regionen erreichen sie nur zu fuß und
der osten ist bunt wir haben mir sogar
alten im internet
die sorgen dass uns sowas wie
tschechische denen die ukrainisch reden
und finnisch aussehen also ich meine
gibt die tragen kopftuch im prinzip eine
brandenburg und sie wollten schon immer
ein konto in der schweiz warum nicht ein
zwischen schweiz
in der sächsischen schweiz ist es so
dünn besiedelt beim öffnen des eines
kontos alten sie eine ganze
sparkassenfiliale für sie gratis dazu
ich habe nur einen wichtigen
reisehinweis meiden sie in sachsen nach
sonnenuntergang kleinere gemeinden
mittlere gemeinden und größere städte
der rest ist absolut sie haben sie
appetit bekommen dann schauen sie doch
einmal vorbei absolut oder shorts
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen tag menschen überall
lassen ihre risiken liegen und ihr lasst
jetzt slx ein beschissenes abo da
[Musik]